This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back. Welcome to the podcast. Thanks for tuning in. I hope you're all having a splendid day wherever you are in the world. Let's jump right into it. Today, we're. talking about something a little bit different. We're talking about social attraction in groups and what it means to be perceived as cool. I've been thinking about this a lot. Shout out to a friend of mine who I've been having some conversations with this about conversations around status,
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back. Welcome to the podcast. Thanks for tuning in. I hope you're all having a splendid day wherever you are in the world. Let's jump right into it. Today, we're. talking about something a little bit different. We're talking about social attraction in groups and what it means to be perceived as cool. I've been thinking about this a lot. Shout out to a friend of mine who I've been having some conversations with this about conversations around status,|||Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everyone. Welcome back. Welcome to the podcast. Thanks for tuning in. I hope you're all having a splendid day wherever you are in the world. Let's jump right into it. Today, we're. talking about something a little bit different. We're talking about social attraction in groups and what it means to be perceived as cool. I've been thinking about this a lot. Shout out to a friend of mine who I've been having some conversations with this about conversations around status,
around the anxiety that comes with the acknowledgement that you're perceived by others, wanting to fit in, wanting to seem cool. And it all kind of ties to. together and there's a pretty interesting narrative around these topics in psychology and in social psychology. So I thought it would be a great episode to talk about and to talk through today. Before we get into it, though, I just want to say, if you are an existing listener of the podcast, I hope you like the new artwork. I updated the cover art and have like rebranded the podcast. Still the same content, obviously. But let me know what you think. I did do it. like a little mini poll on my Instagram.
around the anxiety that comes with the acknowledgement that you're perceived by others, wanting to fit in, wanting to seem cool. And it all kind of ties to. together and there's a pretty interesting narrative around these topics in psychology and in social psychology. So I thought it would be a great episode to talk about and to talk through today. Before we get into it, though, I just want to say, if you are an existing listener of the podcast, I hope you like the new artwork. I updated the cover art and have like rebranded the podcast. Still the same content, obviously. But let me know what you think. I did do it. like a little mini poll on my Instagram.|||around the anxiety that comes with the acknowledgement that you're perceived by others, wanting to fit in, wanting to seem cool. And it all kind of ties to. together and there's a pretty interesting narrative around these topics in psychology and in social psychology. So I thought it would be a great episode to talk about and to talk through today. Before we get into it, though, I just want to say, if you are an existing listener of the podcast, I hope you like the new artwork. I updated the cover art and have like rebranded the podcast. Still the same content, obviously. But let me know what you think. I did do it. like a little mini poll on my Instagram.
And by far, this new kind of design won out against my shitty Canva designed thing. So, yes, new stage, new season of the podcast. Additionally, huge, huge moment for the podcast coming up. We are about to celebrate one year of the psychology of your 20s. That's right. I started this podcast a year ago in mid-late June. I'll obviously announce it when I get to that stage. But if you listen to the Heartbreak episode,
And by far, this new kind of design won out against my shitty Canva designed thing. So, yes, new stage, new season of the podcast. Additionally, huge, huge moment for the podcast coming up. We are about to celebrate one year of the psychology of your 20s. That's right. I started this podcast a year ago in mid-late June. I'll obviously announce it when I get to that stage. But if you listen to the Heartbreak episode,|||And by far, this new kind of design won out against my shitty Canva designed thing. So, yes, new stage, new season of the podcast. Additionally, huge, huge moment for the podcast coming up. We are about to celebrate one year of the psychology of your 20s. That's right. I started this podcast a year ago in mid-late June. I'll obviously announce it when I get to that stage. But if you listen to the Heartbreak episode,
you would know why I started this podcast to begin with. And yeah, it's just crazy to look back on this year and what this kind of platform and, you know, just being able to talk through these things and investigate them and think about them, how much that's kind of really benefited me and all the growth that I've been through in that year. And thanks for supporting me
you would know why I started this podcast to begin with. And yeah, it's just crazy to look back on this year and what this kind of platform and, you know, just being able to talk through these things and investigate them and think about them, how much that's kind of really benefited me and all the growth that I've been through in that year. And thanks for supporting me|||you would know why I started this podcast to begin with. And yeah, it's just crazy to look back on this year and what this kind of platform and, you know, just being able to talk through these things and investigate them and think about them, how much that's kind of really benefited me and all the growth that I've been through in that year. And thanks for supporting me
throughout this. This was such a new experience for me when I first started and now it's just such a part of my life. It's a part of my identity and it's huge that there are people who reach out every week who say really nice things, people who leave me ratings and all of that stuff. So I really appreciate it. So social attraction, social status. Why does it matter so much in our 20s? Well, I think that these ideas of being part of the in-group, being like, by others are important because it comes down to acceptance. It comes down to feeling like you have a group, feeling like you belong somewhere. That's a really important struggle and experience in our 20s especially because this is really the decade in which you kind of start to place down your
throughout this. This was such a new experience for me when I first started and now it's just such a part of my life. It's a part of my identity and it's huge that there are people who reach out every week who say really nice things, people who leave me ratings and all of that stuff. So I really appreciate it. So social attraction, social status. Why does it matter so much in our 20s? Well, I think that these ideas of being part of the in-group, being like, by others are important because it comes down to acceptance. It comes down to feeling like you have a group, feeling like you belong somewhere. That's a really important struggle and experience in our 20s especially because this is really the decade in which you kind of start to place down your|||throughout this. This was such a new experience for me when I first started and now it's just such a part of my life. It's a part of my identity and it's huge that there are people who reach out every week who say really nice things, people who leave me ratings and all of that stuff. So I really appreciate it. So social attraction, social status. Why does it matter so much in our 20s? Well, I think that these ideas of being part of the in-group, being like, by others are important because it comes down to acceptance. It comes down to feeling like you have a group, feeling like you belong somewhere. That's a really important struggle and experience in our 20s especially because this is really the decade in which you kind of start to place down your
foundations. You try out different identities. You shift between different social groups and you're really trying to find your feet and how you relate to others, the interactions you have with others, and where you feel that you belong. And what comes with that is an intense pressure around other people's perceptions of us, around other people's perception of our social status, of our likeability, our whether we could be accepted into their group. And where does this pressure and influence kind of come from? That's something we're really going to discuss today. I'm sure we've all felt that feeling of just like not fitting in, not really jelling with people, feeling really lame. And it's a really terrible feeling. We've all been there and we've all felt
foundations. You try out different identities. You shift between different social groups and you're really trying to find your feet and how you relate to others, the interactions you have with others, and where you feel that you belong. And what comes with that is an intense pressure around other people's perceptions of us, around other people's perception of our social status, of our likeability, our whether we could be accepted into their group. And where does this pressure and influence kind of come from? That's something we're really going to discuss today. I'm sure we've all felt that feeling of just like not fitting in, not really jelling with people, feeling really lame. And it's a really terrible feeling. We've all been there and we've all felt|||foundations. You try out different identities. You shift between different social groups and you're really trying to find your feet and how you relate to others, the interactions you have with others, and where you feel that you belong. And what comes with that is an intense pressure around other people's perceptions of us, around other people's perception of our social status, of our likeability, our whether we could be accepted into their group. And where does this pressure and influence kind of come from? That's something we're really going to discuss today. I'm sure we've all felt that feeling of just like not fitting in, not really jelling with people, feeling really lame. And it's a really terrible feeling. We've all been there and we've all felt
it. But it's somewhat intangible and this sense of not fitting in and this desire to be seen as cool. It kind of operates in our social domains. But to a large extent, it also comes from our private thoughts and our assessments of others and our memberships to groups that we deem as important to our identity. All of these things, although we can see them, we can't really hold them. They're quite intangible and they really operate without much explanation. The groups we are a part of, specifically our in groups, which we're going to talk a lot about today, are incredibly influential in our 20s and for the rest of our lives. And a large part of this is to do with social and personal attraction, wanting to be,
it. But it's somewhat intangible and this sense of not fitting in and this desire to be seen as cool. It kind of operates in our social domains. But to a large extent, it also comes from our private thoughts and our assessments of others and our memberships to groups that we deem as important to our identity. All of these things, although we can see them, we can't really hold them. They're quite intangible and they really operate without much explanation. The groups we are a part of, specifically our in groups, which we're going to talk a lot about today, are incredibly influential in our 20s and for the rest of our lives. And a large part of this is to do with social and personal attraction, wanting to be,|||it. But it's somewhat intangible and this sense of not fitting in and this desire to be seen as cool. It kind of operates in our social domains. But to a large extent, it also comes from our private thoughts and our assessments of others and our memberships to groups that we deem as important to our identity. All of these things, although we can see them, we can't really hold them. They're quite intangible and they really operate without much explanation. The groups we are a part of, specifically our in groups, which we're going to talk a lot about today, are incredibly influential in our 20s and for the rest of our lives. And a large part of this is to do with social and personal attraction, wanting to be,
accepted into a group, wanting to seem like an attractive individual, not in the physical sense, but in kind of the social sense. And another important element that I really want to discuss is relative and comparative status. So much of how we see ourselves comes from our comparison to others and to where they stand. And they're kind of position in this invisible hierarchy, this invisible social hierarchy that we all kind of know exists. essentially we want people to like us we want to be accepted and to be perceived as high status whatever that means based on our social memberships so how do our brains navigate the complexity around this problem why does it come so naturally to to some people what is it that makes certain individuals
accepted into a group, wanting to seem like an attractive individual, not in the physical sense, but in kind of the social sense. And another important element that I really want to discuss is relative and comparative status. So much of how we see ourselves comes from our comparison to others and to where they stand. And they're kind of position in this invisible hierarchy, this invisible social hierarchy that we all kind of know exists. essentially we want people to like us we want to be accepted and to be perceived as high status whatever that means based on our social memberships so how do our brains navigate the complexity around this problem why does it come so naturally to to some people what is it that makes certain individuals|||accepted into a group, wanting to seem like an attractive individual, not in the physical sense, but in kind of the social sense. And another important element that I really want to discuss is relative and comparative status. So much of how we see ourselves comes from our comparison to others and to where they stand. And they're kind of position in this invisible hierarchy, this invisible social hierarchy that we all kind of know exists. essentially we want people to like us we want to be accepted and to be perceived as high status whatever that means based on our social memberships so how do our brains navigate the complexity around this problem why does it come so naturally to to some people what is it that makes certain individuals
trendsetters and another big thing we're going to discuss is around subcultures and how they operate how norms take hold. So like I've said numerous times and it's a pretty known social reality, you're listening to this, you want to be liked, I want to be liked, we want to be seen as part of the us or as standing out or being cool, especially in our early 20s where social status and interpersonal attraction really matter as we navigate our identity and who we are. I say this all the time on the podcast, but humans are social. animals and being rejected from a social group that we deem as important in the past what that meant was losing access to things that were essential for our survival like food protection
trendsetters and another big thing we're going to discuss is around subcultures and how they operate how norms take hold. So like I've said numerous times and it's a pretty known social reality, you're listening to this, you want to be liked, I want to be liked, we want to be seen as part of the us or as standing out or being cool, especially in our early 20s where social status and interpersonal attraction really matter as we navigate our identity and who we are. I say this all the time on the podcast, but humans are social. animals and being rejected from a social group that we deem as important in the past what that meant was losing access to things that were essential for our survival like food protection|||trendsetters and another big thing we're going to discuss is around subcultures and how they operate how norms take hold. So like I've said numerous times and it's a pretty known social reality, you're listening to this, you want to be liked, I want to be liked, we want to be seen as part of the us or as standing out or being cool, especially in our early 20s where social status and interpersonal attraction really matter as we navigate our identity and who we are. I say this all the time on the podcast, but humans are social. animals and being rejected from a social group that we deem as important in the past what that meant was losing access to things that were essential for our survival like food protection
mating partners so to survive our brains have kind of developed an early warning rejection alert system that triggers really sharp emotional pain and sometimes the feeling of physical pain as well that's how deeply we don't want to be rejected and how deeply we crave acceptance. But for so many years, few psychologists in this area have really tuned into the importance of rejection for shaping our behaviour. It's like the whole field kind of missed this centrally important part of human life. But that's changed over the last decade and a growing number of researchers and institutions have really turned their eyes towards this uncomfortable factor.
mating partners so to survive our brains have kind of developed an early warning rejection alert system that triggers really sharp emotional pain and sometimes the feeling of physical pain as well that's how deeply we don't want to be rejected and how deeply we crave acceptance. But for so many years, few psychologists in this area have really tuned into the importance of rejection for shaping our behaviour. It's like the whole field kind of missed this centrally important part of human life. But that's changed over the last decade and a growing number of researchers and institutions have really turned their eyes towards this uncomfortable factor.|||mating partners so to survive our brains have kind of developed an early warning rejection alert system that triggers really sharp emotional pain and sometimes the feeling of physical pain as well that's how deeply we don't want to be rejected and how deeply we crave acceptance. But for so many years, few psychologists in this area have really tuned into the importance of rejection for shaping our behaviour. It's like the whole field kind of missed this centrally important part of human life. But that's changed over the last decade and a growing number of researchers and institutions have really turned their eyes towards this uncomfortable factor.
of life, that rejection, it matters to us. People have realized just how much our concern with social acceptance kind of spreads its fingers into almost everything we do, everything. And I was having this conversation with a friend of mine around how you navigate that. Do we just accept that social pressure and the desire to appear like you have status or to be accepted? Do we just accept that that exists and live within that system and kind of play along with it? Or just, you kind of face that constant existential treadmill of trying to fight against it, but never quite being able to. But back to the research. So as researchers have kind of dug deeper into the roots of rejection, they found some pretty surprising evidence that the pain of being excluded is not
of life, that rejection, it matters to us. People have realized just how much our concern with social acceptance kind of spreads its fingers into almost everything we do, everything. And I was having this conversation with a friend of mine around how you navigate that. Do we just accept that social pressure and the desire to appear like you have status or to be accepted? Do we just accept that that exists and live within that system and kind of play along with it? Or just, you kind of face that constant existential treadmill of trying to fight against it, but never quite being able to. But back to the research. So as researchers have kind of dug deeper into the roots of rejection, they found some pretty surprising evidence that the pain of being excluded is not|||of life, that rejection, it matters to us. People have realized just how much our concern with social acceptance kind of spreads its fingers into almost everything we do, everything. And I was having this conversation with a friend of mine around how you navigate that. Do we just accept that social pressure and the desire to appear like you have status or to be accepted? Do we just accept that that exists and live within that system and kind of play along with it? Or just, you kind of face that constant existential treadmill of trying to fight against it, but never quite being able to. But back to the research. So as researchers have kind of dug deeper into the roots of rejection, they found some pretty surprising evidence that the pain of being excluded is not
so different from the pain of physical injury, of stumbling your toe, things like that. And rejection, it also has pretty serious implications for your psychological. state and for the state of society in general. Social rejection it influences your emotions. It influences your cognition and your physical health and ostracize people if rejection happens again and again can become very isolated and even aggressive or turn violent. I think that the idea of social rejection has really become part of an ongoing conversation around things like school shooters in the US or lone war. wolves or people who from that rejection have gone on to do terrible things.
so different from the pain of physical injury, of stumbling your toe, things like that. And rejection, it also has pretty serious implications for your psychological. state and for the state of society in general. Social rejection it influences your emotions. It influences your cognition and your physical health and ostracize people if rejection happens again and again can become very isolated and even aggressive or turn violent. I think that the idea of social rejection has really become part of an ongoing conversation around things like school shooters in the US or lone war. wolves or people who from that rejection have gone on to do terrible things.|||so different from the pain of physical injury, of stumbling your toe, things like that. And rejection, it also has pretty serious implications for your psychological. state and for the state of society in general. Social rejection it influences your emotions. It influences your cognition and your physical health and ostracize people if rejection happens again and again can become very isolated and even aggressive or turn violent. I think that the idea of social rejection has really become part of an ongoing conversation around things like school shooters in the US or lone war. wolves or people who from that rejection have gone on to do terrible things.
And it's really, really interesting how our conversations around that have really integrated this idea and this acceptance of rejection as a bad thing into our discussions of these instances and these people. Because humans, we have a fundamental need to belong. Just as we have needs for food and water, we also have needs for positive and lasting relationships. So if we're hardwired to avoid rejection, where do we seek acceptance and approval? Well, that would be from the groups that we are a part of, all of us, every single person listening to this. I'm sure that you can name at least four, five groups that you're a part of. Maybe it's a
And it's really, really interesting how our conversations around that have really integrated this idea and this acceptance of rejection as a bad thing into our discussions of these instances and these people. Because humans, we have a fundamental need to belong. Just as we have needs for food and water, we also have needs for positive and lasting relationships. So if we're hardwired to avoid rejection, where do we seek acceptance and approval? Well, that would be from the groups that we are a part of, all of us, every single person listening to this. I'm sure that you can name at least four, five groups that you're a part of. Maybe it's a|||And it's really, really interesting how our conversations around that have really integrated this idea and this acceptance of rejection as a bad thing into our discussions of these instances and these people. Because humans, we have a fundamental need to belong. Just as we have needs for food and water, we also have needs for positive and lasting relationships. So if we're hardwired to avoid rejection, where do we seek acceptance and approval? Well, that would be from the groups that we are a part of, all of us, every single person listening to this. I'm sure that you can name at least four, five groups that you're a part of. Maybe it's a
sport team. It's the place that you work. It's your group of friends. It's your family. It's your neighborhood. It's the school you went to. But some groups matter more to us. and others based on what we personally value about ourselves, but also how we perceive others and how we perceive our groups in relation to society in general. It also comes down to whether we like people, yes, but whether we see our groups and the groups that maybe we're not part of as an opportunity for social mobility. So social mobility comes into this conversation a lot.
sport team. It's the place that you work. It's your group of friends. It's your family. It's your neighborhood. It's the school you went to. But some groups matter more to us. and others based on what we personally value about ourselves, but also how we perceive others and how we perceive our groups in relation to society in general. It also comes down to whether we like people, yes, but whether we see our groups and the groups that maybe we're not part of as an opportunity for social mobility. So social mobility comes into this conversation a lot.|||sport team. It's the place that you work. It's your group of friends. It's your family. It's your neighborhood. It's the school you went to. But some groups matter more to us. and others based on what we personally value about ourselves, but also how we perceive others and how we perceive our groups in relation to society in general. It also comes down to whether we like people, yes, but whether we see our groups and the groups that maybe we're not part of as an opportunity for social mobility. So social mobility comes into this conversation a lot.
Status, it exists. Social status and a hierarchy of different social. social groups exist. And if we are seeking approval, it kind of makes sense that we'd want that approval to come from the people that are most admired in society. And by gaining access to those groups, we experience social mobility, we move up, we improve our self-esteem, and we reduce the feelings of rejection or the feelings of not really belonging. So we like those and we like groups that present an opportunity to be liked and included. And this leads to conformity and a convergence on group norms which end up governing our behaviour. Many people, all of us, we like
Status, it exists. Social status and a hierarchy of different social. social groups exist. And if we are seeking approval, it kind of makes sense that we'd want that approval to come from the people that are most admired in society. And by gaining access to those groups, we experience social mobility, we move up, we improve our self-esteem, and we reduce the feelings of rejection or the feelings of not really belonging. So we like those and we like groups that present an opportunity to be liked and included. And this leads to conformity and a convergence on group norms which end up governing our behaviour. Many people, all of us, we like|||Status, it exists. Social status and a hierarchy of different social. social groups exist. And if we are seeking approval, it kind of makes sense that we'd want that approval to come from the people that are most admired in society. And by gaining access to those groups, we experience social mobility, we move up, we improve our self-esteem, and we reduce the feelings of rejection or the feelings of not really belonging. So we like those and we like groups that present an opportunity to be liked and included. And this leads to conformity and a convergence on group norms which end up governing our behaviour. Many people, all of us, we like
to recognise ourselves as an individual or as unique. And whilst we do possess specific characteristics that really distinguish us from the crowd, we are all unique, the majority of us comply with some set of social and societal rules most of the time. So conformity is the act of kind of matching your beliefs, your attitudes and behaviours to group norms, politics or to those who are like-minded. Norms, there are these implicit, specific rules, intangible really, that are shared by a group of individuals and they guide our interactions with others. And it kind of brings up the question, we've kind of already answered it, but just to reiterate, why do people conform to these norms? Why do people conform in a group? Well, yielding to group pressure in this way, it often happens because we want to fit in.
to recognise ourselves as an individual or as unique. And whilst we do possess specific characteristics that really distinguish us from the crowd, we are all unique, the majority of us comply with some set of social and societal rules most of the time. So conformity is the act of kind of matching your beliefs, your attitudes and behaviours to group norms, politics or to those who are like-minded. Norms, there are these implicit, specific rules, intangible really, that are shared by a group of individuals and they guide our interactions with others. And it kind of brings up the question, we've kind of already answered it, but just to reiterate, why do people conform to these norms? Why do people conform in a group? Well, yielding to group pressure in this way, it often happens because we want to fit in.|||to recognise ourselves as an individual or as unique. And whilst we do possess specific characteristics that really distinguish us from the crowd, we are all unique, the majority of us comply with some set of social and societal rules most of the time. So conformity is the act of kind of matching your beliefs, your attitudes and behaviours to group norms, politics or to those who are like-minded. Norms, there are these implicit, specific rules, intangible really, that are shared by a group of individuals and they guide our interactions with others. And it kind of brings up the question, we've kind of already answered it, but just to reiterate, why do people conform to these norms? Why do people conform in a group? Well, yielding to group pressure in this way, it often happens because we want to fit in.
And there are these five proposed kind of motivations behind conformity of this type. So the reasons that we conform and we converge on the group norms of groups that we deem is important are because we want to be correct. We want to be socially acceptable and avoid rejection. we want to accomplish group goals that could in turn help elevate our social status or our social position and how well off we are. We also conform to establish and maintain our self-concept and our social identity and to align ourselves with similar individuals. And there is kind of this general belief that conforming is pretty important for society. It makes us more agreeable to live with.
And there are these five proposed kind of motivations behind conformity of this type. So the reasons that we conform and we converge on the group norms of groups that we deem as important are because we want to be correct. We want to be socially acceptable and avoid rejection. we want to accomplish group goals that could in turn help elevate our social status or our social position and how well off we are. We also conform to establish and maintain our self-concept and our social identity and to align ourselves with similar individuals. And there is kind of this general belief that conforming is pretty important for society. It makes us more agreeable to live with.|||And there are these five proposed kind of motivations behind conformity of this type. So the reasons that we conform and we converge on the group norms of groups that we deem as important are because we want to be correct. We want to be socially acceptable and avoid rejection. we want to accomplish group goals that could in turn help elevate our social status or our social position and how well off we are. We also conform to establish and maintain our self-concept and our social identity and to align ourselves with similar individuals. And there is kind of this general belief that conforming is pretty important for society. It makes us more agreeable to live with.
and in some ways it kind of creates a status quo or a sense of normal. And different groups, different identities, they have different definitions of the norms which govern our behaviour and which norms you need to follow to be seen or deemed as acceptable. So importantly, although traditional ideas of in-group acceptance often speak of conformity and obedience to the norm is the most important part of being accepted, It actually appears a lot more nuanced, the deeper that you kind of dive into the literature. And what is cool or what is socially acceptable and no longer seems to just be based on conformity, but in some ways, rebellion and violation.
and in some ways it kind of creates a status quo or a sense of normal. And different groups, different identities, they have different definitions of the norms which govern our behaviour and which norms you need to follow to be seen or deemed as acceptable. So importantly, although traditional ideas of in-group acceptance often speak of conformity and obedience to the norm is the most important part of being accepted, It actually appears a lot more nuanced, the deeper that you kind of dive into the literature. And what is cool or what is socially acceptable and no longer seems to just be based on conformity, but in some ways, rebellion and violation.|||and in some ways it kind of creates a status quo or a sense of normal. And different groups, different identities, they have different definitions of the norms which govern our behaviour and which norms you need to follow to be seen or deemed as acceptable. So importantly, although traditional ideas of in-group acceptance often speak of conformity and obedience to the norm is the most important part of being accepted, It actually appears a lot more nuanced, the deeper that you kind of dive into the literature. And what is cool or what is socially acceptable and no longer seems to just be based on conformity, but in some ways, rebellion and violation.
So researchers, they've tried to kind of unpack the paradoxes that are inherent in social acceptance and being perceived as one of us and as cool. And they have obviously focused in particular on norms, but more so on the importance of violating norms or setting. oneself apart from certain dispensable norms. So one author, this really interesting author, did this in-depth study on why norm violation can actually lead to acceptance and attraction. So norm violation, that being going against what is traditionally accepted or expected from you. And the conventional wisdom is that violating a norm would result in rejection, which we know we want
So researchers, they've tried to kind of unpack the paradoxes that are inherent in social acceptance and being perceived as one of us and as cool. And they have obviously focused in particular on norms, but more so on the importance of violating norms or setting. oneself apart from certain dispensable norms. So one author, this really interesting author, did this in-depth study on why norm violation can actually lead to acceptance and attraction. So norm violation, that being going against what is traditionally accepted or expected from you. And the conventional wisdom is that violating a norm would result in rejection, which we know we want|||So researchers, they've tried to kind of unpack the paradoxes that are inherent in social acceptance and being perceived as one of us and as cool. And they have obviously focused in particular on norms, but more so on the importance of violating norms or setting. oneself apart from certain dispensable norms. So one author, this really interesting author, did this in-depth study on why norm violation can actually lead to acceptance and attraction. So norm violation, that being going against what is traditionally accepted or expected from you. And the conventional wisdom is that violating a norm would result in rejection, which we know we want
to avoid. So people normally have an incentive. to be as loyal and obedient to the norms set by their groups as possible. But the things with norms, the thing with norms, sorry, is that they are contextually and situationally specific. Humans do not have one set of norms that are universal and that we're all beholden to. They differ. And the unwritten behavioral and attitudinal codes that govern our lives, they differ from situation to situation from group to group and like I said they're importantly fixed to certain groups
to avoid. So people normally have an incentive. to be as loyal and obedient to the norms set by their groups as possible. But the things with norms, the thing with norms, sorry, is that they are contextually and situationally specific. Humans do not have one set of norms that are universal and that we're all beholden to. They differ. And the unwritten behavioral and attitudinal codes that govern our lives, they differ from situation to situation from group to group and like I said they're importantly fixed to certain groups|||to avoid. So people normally have an incentive. to be as loyal and obedient to the norms set by their groups as possible. But the things with norms, the thing with norms, sorry, is that they are contextually and situationally specific. Humans do not have one set of norms that are universal and that we're all beholden to. They differ. And the unwritten behavioral and attitudinal codes that govern our lives, they differ from situation to situation from group to group and like I said they're importantly fixed to certain groups
and our memberships to them. So we are aware of the different norms that exist in different contexts. So how you behave at work, what's expected of you will differ wildly from how you behave when you're on like a rowdy night out with your friends. But norms are the building blocks of being liked and being perceived as part of the in-group and as cool. But as I've mentioned, it's a complicated process and interactions. And as researchers have pointed out recently, sometimes it is norm violation that can be most influential for social mobility and acceptance. I think cool and being cool has kind of this really strange, brittle, cultural logic. It's kind of a residual code that has turned itself into an emerging code. Its performative style is based upon and derives simultaneously
and our memberships to them. So we are aware of the different norms that exist in different contexts. So how you behave at work, what's expected of you will differ wildly from how you behave when you're on like a rowdy night out with your friends. But norms are the building blocks of being liked and being perceived as part of the in-group and as cool. But as I've mentioned, it's a complicated process and interactions. And as researchers have pointed out recently, sometimes it is norm violation that can be most influential for social mobility and acceptance. I think cool and being cool has kind of this really strange, brittle, cultural logic. It's kind of a residual code that has turned itself into an emerging code. Its performative style is based upon and derives simultaneously|||and our memberships to them. So we are aware of the different norms that exist in different contexts. So how you behave at work, what's expected of you will differ wildly from how you behave when you're on like a rowdy night out with your friends. But norms are the building blocks of being liked and being perceived as part of the in-group and as cool. But as I've mentioned, it's a complicated process and interactions. And as researchers have pointed out recently, sometimes it is norm violation that can be most influential for social mobility and acceptance. I think cool and being cool has kind of this really strange, brittle, cultural logic. It's kind of a residual code that has turned itself into an emerging code. Its performative style is based upon and derives simultaneously
from symbols of both association, but also of independence and disaffiliation. So for example, the norms held by broader society versus the norms held by unique subgroups that we are a part of, they'll differ. So you can simultaneously break a norm and obey a different norm at the same time. And by breaking a more widely held norm of broader society that maybe not everyone agrees with, we can kind of signal to our unique subgroups that we're more loyal to the codes that govern our behaviour in these unique and smaller scale situations. So acceptance and being perceived as cool or as part of the in-group nowadays can actually mean breaking the rules, violating the norm, but only to a certain degree.
from symbols of both association, but also of independence and disaffiliation. So for example, the norms held by broader society versus the norms held by unique subgroups that we are a part of, they'll differ. So you can simultaneously break a norm and obey a different norm at the same time. And by breaking a more widely held norm of broader society that maybe not everyone agrees with, we can kind of signal to our unique subgroups that we're more loyal to the codes that govern our behaviour in these unique and smaller scale situations. So acceptance and being perceived as cool or as part of the in-group nowadays can actually mean breaking the rules, violating the norm, but only to a certain degree.|||from symbols of both association, but also of independence and disaffiliation. So for example, the norms held by broader society versus the norms held by unique subgroups that we are a part of, they'll differ. So you can simultaneously break a norm and obey a different norm at the same time. And by breaking a more widely held norm of broader society that maybe not everyone agrees with, we can kind of signal to our unique subgroups that we're more loyal to the codes that govern our behaviour in these unique and smaller scale situations. So acceptance and being perceived as cool or as part of the in-group nowadays can actually mean breaking the rules, violating the norm, but only to a certain degree.
So according to one researcher, the way people and things are perceived as cool is if they're seen as autonomous. It's not just about always going against the norm and expecting people to like you based on the logic we were talking about above. We want to, you know, people, we want to see people, we want to see their actions as if they would do them regardless of what other people think. let me kind of repeat that. Violating a norm just to violate it for the sake of it isn't actually seen as very beneficial. But if you're doing it in an autonomous way, if you're doing it for some superordinate goal and in a way that is very unique or seems really self-motivated, that's when you're more likely to gain acceptance from your unique subgroups. Furthermore, norm violation, it not only indicates that you can be an independent thinker and that you're autonomous,
So according to one researcher, the way people and things are perceived as cool is if they're seen as autonomous. It's not just about always going against the norm and expecting people to like you based on the logic we were talking about above. We want to, you know, people, we want to see people, we want to see their actions as if they would do them regardless of what other people think. let me kind of repeat that. Violating a norm just to violate it for the sake of it isn't actually seen as very beneficial. But if you're doing it in an autonomous way, if you're doing it for some superordinate goal and in a way that is very unique or seems really self-motivated, that's when you're more likely to gain acceptance from your unique subgroups. Furthermore, norm violation, it not only indicates that you can be an independent thinker and that you're autonomous,|||So according to one researcher, the way people and things are perceived as cool is if they're seen as autonomous. It's not just about always going against the norm and expecting people to like you based on the logic we were talking about above. We want to, you know, people, we want to see people, we want to see their actions as if they would do them regardless of what other people think. let me kind of repeat that. Violating a norm just to violate it for the sake of it isn't actually seen as very beneficial. But if you're doing it in an autonomous way, if you're doing it for some superordinate goal and in a way that is very unique or seems really self-motivated, that's when you're more likely to gain acceptance from your unique subgroups. Furthermore, norm violation, it not only indicates that you can be an independent thinker and that you're autonomous,
but that you operate in the way that favours the more specific inner group norms of your groups without needing direction or instruction. So it kind of validates that you are actually a true member of the group, and in that way you begin to receive social acceptance. A really interesting kind of example of this is the idea of style and how we dress. I was talking about this with my friend Sydney. We both live in, I would say pretty cool neighborhoods in Melbourne and Sydney, pretty big cities, pretty cool cities. And there is definitely this very, I think, fluid idea of what makes you seem socially acceptable, what makes people like you.
but that you operate in the way that favours the more specific inner group norms of your groups without needing direction or instruction. So it kind of validates that you are actually a true member of the group, and in that way you begin to receive social acceptance. A really interesting kind of example of this is the idea of style and how we dress. I was talking about this with my friend Sydney. We both live in, I would say pretty cool neighborhoods in Melbourne and Sydney, pretty big cities, pretty cool cities. And there is definitely this very, I think, fluid idea of what makes you seem socially acceptable, what makes people like you.|||but that you operate in the way that favours the more specific inner group norms of your groups without needing direction or instruction. So it kind of validates that you are actually a true member of the group, and in that way you begin to receive social acceptance. A really interesting kind of example of this is the idea of style and how we dress. I was talking about this with my friend Sydney. We both live in, I would say pretty cool neighborhoods in Melbourne and Sydney, pretty big cities, pretty cool cities. And there is definitely this very, I think, fluid idea of what makes you seem socially acceptable, what makes people like you.
And there is a perception these days that rejecting trends and choosing kind of a niche, unique look, shopping at op-shops or having kind of a look or a style that's one of a kind, I guess that's what's cool, because it shows a rejection of popular fashion and dress that can be used to signal independence, but also allegiance to a more contradictory and anti-establishment trend that exists within the certain subgroups that we may be a part of. Norm violation has become cool, making it such that kind of the new norm is to be anti-norm. It's like a bit of a contradiction, but an interesting thing to think about nonetheless. It becomes more about, in this situation, independence and uniqueness over norm loyalty.
And there is a perception these days that rejecting trends and choosing kind of a niche, unique look, shopping at op-shops or having kind of a look or a style that's one of a kind, I guess that's what's cool, because it shows a rejection of popular fashion and dress that can be used to signal independence, but also allegiance to a more contradictory and anti-establishment trend that exists within the certain subgroups that we may be a part of. Norm violation has become cool, making it such that kind of the new norm is to be anti-norm. It's like a bit of a contradiction, but an interesting thing to think about nonetheless. It becomes more about, in this situation, independence and uniqueness over norm loyalty.|||And there is a perception these days that rejecting trends and choosing kind of a niche, unique look, shopping at op-shops or having kind of a look or a style that's one of a kind, I guess that's what's cool, because it shows a rejection of popular fashion and dress that can be used to signal independence, but also allegiance to a more contradictory and anti-establishment trend that exists within the certain subgroups that we may be a part of. Norm violation has become cool, making it such that kind of the new norm is to be anti-norm. It's like a bit of a contradiction, but an interesting thing to think about nonetheless. It becomes more about, in this situation, independence and uniqueness over norm loyalty.
And that's when autonomy itself becomes the norm and becomes how we gain social acceptance. So in some sense, coolness, our desire to be seen as socially and interpersonally attractive, mirrors the self-actualization process. Self-actualizes, they're people who think for themselves. They don't conform to fit in, and they've kind of evolved beyond basic needs to higher order needs. Instead of valuing things like belonging, they've come to value higher principles like self-sufficiency, like beauty that is independent of traditional conceptions of the subject and things like justice. So Maslow, he is this well-known psychologist, this author, this thinker, and he describes self-actualizers as autonomous, standing apart from their culture and environment in important ways. They might break or reject the rules of broader society that just don't make sense.
And that's when autonomy itself becomes the norm and becomes how we gain social acceptance. So in some sense, coolness, our desire to be seen as socially and interpersonally attractive, mirrors the self-actualization process. Self-actualizes, they're people who think for themselves. They don't conform to fit in, and they've kind of evolved beyond basic needs to higher order needs. Instead of valuing things like belonging, they've come to value higher principles like self-sufficiency, like beauty that is independent of traditional conceptions of the subject and things like justice. So Maslow, he is this well-known psychologist, this author, this thinker, and he describes self-actualizers as autonomous, standing apart from their culture and environment in important ways. They might break or reject the rules of broader society that just don't make sense.|||And that's when autonomy itself becomes the norm and becomes how we gain social acceptance. So in some sense, coolness, our desire to be seen as socially and interpersonally attractive, mirrors the self-actualization process. Self-actualizes, they're people who think for themselves. They don't conform to fit in, and they've kind of evolved beyond basic needs to higher order needs. Instead of valuing things like belonging, they've come to value higher principles like self-sufficiency, like beauty that is independent of traditional conceptions of the subject and things like justice. So Maslow, he is this well-known psychologist, this author, this thinker, and he describes self-actualizers as autonomous, standing apart from their culture and environment in important ways. They might break or reject the rules of broader society that just don't make sense.
They might not be as dependent on others for satisfaction or on cost. culture or means to an ends in general to receive extrinsic satisfactions. Rather, they're dependent for their own development and continued growth. And in this way, they kind of set themselves apart and can become accepted for that very reason. Self-actualization, though, importantly, it doesn't occur in isolation. Our identity is not concocted and created. in a bubble, but is influenced every day by what we kind of see in our environment and what is reflected by our in-groups and the subgroups that we're a part of, especially in this kind of day
They might not be as dependent on others for satisfaction or on cost. culture or means to an ends in general to receive extrinsic satisfactions. Rather, they're dependent for their own development and continued growth. And in this way, they kind of set themselves apart and can become accepted for that very reason. Self-actualization, though, importantly, it doesn't occur in isolation. Our identity is not concocted and created. in a bubble, but is influenced every day by what we kind of see in our environment and what is reflected by our in-groups and the subgroups that we're a part of, especially in this kind of day|||They might not be as dependent on others for satisfaction or on cost. culture or means to an ends in general to receive extrinsic satisfactions. Rather, they're dependent for their own development and continued growth. And in this way, they kind of set themselves apart and can become accepted for that very reason. Self-actualization, though, importantly, it doesn't occur in isolation. Our identity is not concocted and created. in a bubble, but is influenced every day by what we kind of see in our environment and what is reflected by our in-groups and the subgroups that we're a part of, especially in this kind of day
and age. I feel like I don't need to expand upon the additional influence of social media and globalization and capitalism. Just essentially, I think the main logic to follow here is that in this day and age there is no such thing as being entirely unique there is no way to separate yourself from trends and the influences of others because they're in yeah i guess the influence is others but also there's no way to really separate yourself from the inherent need to be liked or perceived in a certain way this has more to do just with general social well-being everyone needs community everyone needs in some ways to be liked or they wouldn't be able to operate in modern-day society. I guess a natural progression from that discussion of norm violation and of the power of autonomy and authenticity
and age. I feel like I don't need to expand upon the additional influence of social media and globalization and capitalism. Just essentially, I think the main logic to follow here is that in this day and age there is no such thing as being entirely unique there is no way to separate yourself from trends and the influences of others because they're in yeah i guess the influence is others but also there's no way to really separate yourself from the inherent need to be liked or perceived in a certain way this has more to do just with general social well-being everyone needs community everyone needs in some ways to be liked or they wouldn't be able to operate in modern-day society. I guess a natural progression from that discussion of norm violation and of the power of autonomy and authenticity|||and age. I feel like I don't need to expand upon the additional influence of social media and globalization and capitalism. Just essentially, I think the main logic to follow here is that in this day and age there is no such thing as being entirely unique there is no way to separate yourself from trends and the influences of others because they're in yeah i guess the influence is others but also there's no way to really separate yourself from the inherent need to be liked or perceived in a certain way this has more to do just with general social well-being everyone needs community everyone needs in some ways to be liked or they wouldn't be able to operate in modern-day society. I guess a natural progression from that discussion of norm violation and of the power of autonomy and authenticity
is a discussion on the existence of subgroups and the pressures that they kind of exert upon us. Before we talked a lot about norm violation and in-groups, and I think that does warrant a bit more of a deep dive. In-groups in-particular. because obviously there are norms that govern broader society, but those aren't really the ones that matter because we don't really interact with, we could never possibly interact with every member of society. And I guess it goes without saying that different groups have different expectations.
is a discussion on the existence of subgroups and the pressures that they kind of exert upon us. Before we talked a lot about norm violation and in-groups, and I think that does warrant a bit more of a deep dive. In-groups in-particular. because obviously there are norms that govern broader society, but those aren't really the ones that matter because we don't really interact with, we could never possibly interact with every member of society. And I guess it goes without saying that different groups have different expectations.|||is a discussion on the existence of subgroups and the pressures that they kind of exert upon us. Before we talked a lot about norm violation and in-groups, and I think that does warrant a bit more of a deep dive. In-groups in-particular. because obviously there are norms that govern broader society, but those aren't really the ones that matter because we don't really interact with, we could never possibly interact with every member of society. And I guess it goes without saying that different groups have different expectations.
That's the basis of culture, and that's the basis of, you know, different countries and different groups that we see in the world. So an in-group or a sub-group in psychology and in a large part in the field of sociology as well is a smaller group that exists within a larger group or in this case society. So in-groups are groups which we belong to, which have their own identities, their own interests, attributes, and behavioural norms, and in this way possess their own kind of like insular culture of sorts. For example, an in-group, it could be something like your footy team.
That's the basis of culture, and that's the basis of, you know, different countries and different groups that we see in the world. So an in-group or a sub-group in psychology and in a large part in the field of sociology as well is a smaller group that exists within a larger group or in this case society. So in-groups are groups which we belong to, which have their own identities, their own interests, attributes, and behavioural norms, and in this way possess their own kind of like insular culture of sorts. For example, an in-group, it could be something like your footy team.|||That's the basis of culture, and that's the basis of, you know, different countries and different groups that we see in the world. So an in-group or a sub-group in psychology and in a large part in the field of sociology as well is a smaller group that exists within a larger group or in this case society. So in-groups are groups which we belong to, which have their own identities, their own interests, attributes, and behavioural norms, and in this way possess their own kind of like insular culture of sorts. For example, an in-group, it could be something like your footy team.
You don't have to be a footy player, but just the team that you support. There are a set of attributes that you think, kind of distinguish you from others that creates an in-group. It could be something like the church you go to, in this instance, religion has a big part to do with it. Or it could be something like your neighbourhood. Throughout all these examples, we're saying that there's something that kind of ties people together. And in groups, they can also be based on something incredibly minuscule, even sometimes arbitrary, but which, you know, nonetheless, forms an important part of your identity. Like the music you listen to, that can just be enough for you and someone else to establish an in-group between the two of you.
You don't have to be a footy player, but just the team that you support. There are a set of attributes that you think, kind of distinguish you from others that creates an in-group. It could be something like the church you go to, in this instance, religion has a big part to do with it. Or it could be something like your neighbourhood. Throughout all these examples, we're saying that there's something that kind of ties people together. And in groups, they can also be based on something incredibly minuscule, even sometimes arbitrary, but which, you know, nonetheless, forms an important part of your identity. Like the music you listen to, that can just be enough for you and someone else to establish an in-group between the two of you.|||You don't have to be a footy player, but just the team that you support. There are a set of attributes that you think, kind of distinguish you from others that creates an in-group. It could be something like the church you go to, in this instance, religion has a big part to do with it. Or it could be something like your neighbourhood. Throughout all these examples, we're saying that there's something that kind of ties people together. And in groups, they can also be based on something incredibly minuscule, even sometimes arbitrary, but which, you know, nonetheless, forms an important part of your identity. Like the music you listen to, that can just be enough for you and someone else to establish an in-group between the two of you.
There's something that unites you, which you feel distinguishes you compared to the status quo or everyone else. So subcultures are an important caveat here and kind of like a natural progression from that. So subgroups, they're types of in-groups that are more diffuse. They don't have any formal leadership, formal membership or explicit kind of organizational structure, the way that a church group or a 40 team might have. These are the features, so leadership, formal membership, explicit organizational structure. these are the features which often typify the existence of an in-group, but rather subgroups they have or subcultures have kind of loose and informal participation,
There's something that unites you, which you feel distinguishes you compared to the status quo or everyone else. So subcultures are an important caveat here and kind of like a natural progression from that. So subgroups, they're types of in-groups that are more diffuse. They don't have any formal leadership, formal membership or explicit kind of organizational structure, the way that a church group or a 40 team might have. These are the features, so leadership, formal membership, explicit organizational structure. these are the features which often typify the existence of an in-group, but rather subgroups they have or subcultures have kind of loose and informal participation,|||There's something that unites you, which you feel distinguishes you compared to the status quo or everyone else. So subcultures are an important caveat here and kind of like a natural progression from that. So subgroups, they're types of in-groups that are more diffuse. They don't have any formal leadership, formal membership or explicit kind of organizational structure, the way that a church group or a 40 team might have. These are the features, so leadership, formal membership, explicit organizational structure. these are the features which often typify the existence of an in-group, but rather subgroups they have or subcultures have kind of loose and informal participation,
mainly because the boundaries of who and what embodies a subculture, they're contested and they're fluid. So membership is not exclusive. Subculturalists can identify as just with, just one part of the subculture and simultaneously interact with people in another culture and broader social networks. And consequently, I think the boundaries between mainstream culture and subcultures are often indistinguishable as the two kind of cultural domains. They can share ideas and coexist in the lives of individuals. They can be seen as existing within, whereas in groups kind of is seen as existing outside of.
mainly because the boundaries of who and what embodies a subculture, they're contested and they're fluid. So membership is not exclusive. Subculturalists can identify as just with, just one part of the subculture and simultaneously interact with people in another culture and broader social networks. And consequently, I think the boundaries between mainstream culture and subcultures are often indistinguishable as the two kind of cultural domains. They can share ideas and coexist in the lives of individuals. They can be seen as existing within, whereas in groups kind of is seen as existing outside of.|||mainly because the boundaries of who and what embodies a subculture, they're contested and they're fluid. So membership is not exclusive. Subculturalists can identify as just with, just one part of the subculture and simultaneously interact with people in another culture and broader social networks. And consequently, I think the boundaries between mainstream culture and subcultures are often indistinguishable as the two kind of cultural domains. They can share ideas and coexist in the lives of individuals. They can be seen as existing within, whereas in groups kind of is seen as existing outside of.
and here's why we might actually count subcultures as an in-group. And it kind of does have to do with this broader idea of social attraction that we're talking about. Subcultures, they don't only share an identity. They also share values, practices and cultural objects that if we are a part of this subgroup really matter to us and they often signify status symbols. So, for example, like a particular subculture might be like clean living or like, yeah, clean living veganism, that kind of thing. And they purchase objects of importance to them like, you know, cruelty-free products or
and here's why we might actually count subcultures as an in-group. And it kind of does have to do with this broader idea of social attraction that we're talking about. Subcultures, they don't only share an identity. They also share values, practices and cultural objects that if we are a part of this subgroup really matter to us and they often signify status symbols. So, for example, like a particular subculture might be like clean living or like, yeah, clean living veganism, that kind of thing. And they purchase objects of importance to them like, you know, cruelty-free products or|||and here's why we might actually count subcultures as an in-group. And it kind of does have to do with this broader idea of social attraction that we're talking about. Subcultures, they don't only share an identity. They also share values, practices and cultural objects that if we are a part of this subgroup really matter to us and they often signify status symbols. So, for example, like a particular subculture might be like clean living or like, yeah, clean living veganism, that kind of thing. And they purchase objects of importance to them like, you know, cruelty-free products or
expensive vegan skincare or yoga pants. those things might not be as might not be important to the average person you know someone came up to me in the street and was like oh my gosh here's this fantastic brand of cruelty free sunscreen or whatever um i probably would not know what the fuck they were talking about but it could be a status symbol for that clean living culture or subculture that they operated so as subcultures emerge distinct meanings form to kind of define the specific scenes, unique practices, and cultural objects like the sunscreen. And the other thing that kind of forms is the practices, the principles, and the objects that distinguish the subculture from the mainstream culture.
expensive vegan skincare or yoga pants. those things might not be as might not be important to the average person you know someone came up to me in the street and was like oh my gosh here's this fantastic brand of cruelty free sunscreen or whatever um i probably would not know what the fuck they were talking about but it could be a status symbol for that clean living culture or subculture that they operated so as subcultures emerge distinct meanings form to kind of define the specific scenes, unique practices, and cultural objects like the sunscreen. And the other thing that kind of forms is the practices, the principles, and the objects that distinguish the subculture from the mainstream culture.|||expensive vegan skincare or yoga pants. those things might not be as might not be important to the average person you know someone came up to me in the street and was like oh my gosh here's this fantastic brand of cruelty free sunscreen or whatever um i probably would not know what the fuck they were talking about but it could be a status symbol for that clean living culture or subculture that they operated so as subcultures emerge distinct meanings form to kind of define the specific scenes, unique practices, and cultural objects like the sunscreen. And the other thing that kind of forms is the practices, the principles, and the objects that distinguish the subculture from the mainstream culture.
And it's this chasm, it's this gap that is kind of the biggest one to jump to jump on. over if you want to move into a group if you want to be socially accepted. But luckily for us, the meanings around what is cool or what defines a specific subculture, they continuously grow and change because subcultures don't have any form of leadership or formal membership. So there is freedom to kind of debate existing meanings and create new ones. And additionally, the way that subcultures and in groups are kind of distinguished yet again is that there aren't any kind of barriers to people who are members of subcultures being equally loyal to society and other people in society in general. So it's kind of generally accepted that there are
And it's this chasm, it's this gap that is kind of the biggest one to jump to jump on. over if you want to move into a group if you want to be socially accepted. But luckily for us, the meanings around what is cool or what defines a specific subculture, they continuously grow and change because subcultures don't have any form of leadership or formal membership. So there is freedom to kind of debate existing meanings and create new ones. And additionally, the way that subcultures and in groups are kind of distinguished yet again is that there aren't any kind of barriers to people who are members of subcultures being equally loyal to society and other people in society in general. So it's kind of generally accepted that there are|||And it's this chasm, it's this gap that is kind of the biggest one to jump to jump on. over if you want to move into a group if you want to be socially accepted. But luckily for us, the meanings around what is cool or what defines a specific subculture, they continuously grow and change because subcultures don't have any form of leadership or formal membership. So there is freedom to kind of debate existing meanings and create new ones. And additionally, the way that subcultures and in groups are kind of distinguished yet again is that there aren't any kind of barriers to people who are members of subcultures being equally loyal to society and other people in society in general. So it's kind of generally accepted that there are
interactions between people who aren't really members of the group. And those are just as important as the interactions we have with those who are members of the group. In these situations, the main form of influence and power is common bonds and attachment to other group members and a sense of a strong common identity. So in this way, it's kind of a different idea around social acceptance within these subcultures. In some ways it's easier to seek social acceptance and to be seen as cool or as an in-group member within these kind of settings. but in the other way, in another way, it does take a lot of effort and it takes a lot of
interactions between people who aren't really members of the group. And those are just as important as the interactions we have with those who are members of the group. In these situations, the main form of influence and power is common bonds and attachment to other group members and a sense of a strong common identity. So in this way, it's kind of a different idea around social acceptance within these subcultures. In some ways it's easier to seek social acceptance and to be seen as cool or as an in-group member within these kind of settings. but in the other way, in another way, it does take a lot of effort and it takes a lot of|||interactions between people who aren't really members of the group. And those are just as important as the interactions we have with those who are members of the group. In these situations, the main form of influence and power is common bonds and attachment to other group members and a sense of a strong common identity. So in this way, it's kind of a different idea around social acceptance within these subcultures. In some ways it's easier to seek social acceptance and to be seen as cool or as an in-group member within these kind of settings. but in the other way, in another way, it does take a lot of effort and it takes a lot of
dedication, I guess, to a specific way of living. And another important element that I think really links in with that norm violation concept we were talking about and that perception of being cool relative to context is the sense of resistance within subcultures to kind of the dominant cultural values. And there's also normally a sense of marginalisation that typically unite the, members, they feel that they sit outside of what mainstream culture and cultural values expects from us. Hence, their identity and existence is somewhat predicated on norm violation and going against what is typical. So if we wrap this all and we link this all back together,
dedication, I guess, to a specific way of living. And another important element that I think really links in with that norm violation concept we were talking about and that perception of being cool relative to context is the sense of resistance within subcultures to kind of the dominant cultural values. And there's also normally a sense of marginalisation that typically unite the, members, they feel that they sit outside of what mainstream culture and cultural values expects from us. Hence, their identity and existence is somewhat predicated on norm violation and going against what is typical. So if we wrap this all and we link this all back together,|||dedication, I guess, to a specific way of living. And another important element that I think really links in with that norm violation concept we were talking about and that perception of being cool relative to context is the sense of resistance within subcultures to kind of the dominant cultural values. And there's also normally a sense of marginalisation that typically unite the, members, they feel that they sit outside of what mainstream culture and cultural values expects from us. Hence, their identity and existence is somewhat predicated on norm violation and going against what is typical. So if we wrap this all and we link this all back together,
there's this idea that to be seen as cool and to be seen as part of the in-group and to be seen as socially attractive and socially acceptable, you need to conform. You need to be able to identify what's cool and just follow along with it. But what this recent research is saying is that that really depends because there are actually certain groups in which your membership is based on your ability to go against what is the norm and your ability to act as an autonomous individual. And what makes someone cool or sets people apart within subcultures is often incredibly specific. So I had this thought at a concert the other day.
there's this idea that to be seen as cool and to be seen as part of the in-group and to be seen as socially attractive and socially acceptable, you need to conform. You need to be able to identify what's cool and just follow along with it. But what this recent research is saying is that that really depends because there are actually certain groups in which your membership is based on your ability to go against what is the norm and your ability to act as an autonomous individual. And what makes someone cool or sets people apart within subcultures is often incredibly specific. So I had this thought at a concert the other day.|||there's this idea that to be seen as cool and to be seen as part of the in-group and to be seen as socially attractive and socially acceptable, you need to conform. You need to be able to identify what's cool and just follow along with it. But what this recent research is saying is that that really depends because there are actually certain groups in which your membership is based on your ability to go against what is the norm and your ability to act as an autonomous individual. And what makes someone cool or sets people apart within subcultures is often incredibly specific. So I had this thought at a concert the other day.
I was at Carriageworks. If you're a Sydney listener, you'll know where that is. But this concert, it was like not something I'd take it. I would like normally go to. It was super grunge, kind of goth. And I walked in wearing the clothes that I would normally wear. And I just felt so out of place. I think, you know, if I was walking down the streets of Newtown or if I was at my old
I was at Carriageworks. If you're a Sydney listener, you'll know where that is. But this concert, it was like not something I'd take it. I would like normally go to. It was super grunge, kind of goth. And I walked in wearing the clothes that I would normally wear. And I just felt so out of place. I think, you know, if I was walking down the streets of Newtown or if I was at my old|||I was at Carriageworks. If you're a Sydney listener, you'll know where that is. But this concert, it was like not something I'd take it. I would like normally go to. It was super grunge, kind of goth. And I walked in wearing the clothes that I would normally wear. And I just felt so out of place. I think, you know, if I was walking down the streets of Newtown or if I was at my old
uni what I was wearing the kind of perception I don't know like the kind of image I was giving off would be seen as pretty typical elsewhere but in this situation it was really obvious that I was not a member of this particular subculture I was not a frequent participant in goth underground music that kind of music scene and I felt incredibly uncool but if members of this group were to step into one of my cultural identities or one of the groups I belong to, I'm sure they would have felt the same. And the way that that was kind of indicated to me, the reason I felt uncool was because of these status symbols, because of what people were wearing. And there was a sense of convergence here, but there was also a norm of independence and a norm of authenticity that we've
uni what I was wearing the kind of perception I don't know like the kind of image I was giving off would be seen as pretty typical elsewhere but in this situation it was really obvious that I was not a member of this particular subculture I was not a frequent participant in goth underground music that kind of music scene and I felt incredibly uncool but if members of this group were to step into one of my cultural identities or one of the groups I belong to, I'm sure they would have felt the same. And the way that that was kind of indicated to me, the reason I felt uncool was because of these status symbols, because of what people were wearing. And there was a sense of convergence here, but there was also a norm of independence and a norm of authenticity that we've|||uni what I was wearing the kind of perception I don't know like the kind of image I was giving off would be seen as pretty typical elsewhere but in this situation it was really obvious that I was not a member of this particular subculture I was not a frequent participant in goth underground music that kind of music scene and I felt incredibly uncool but if members of this group were to step into one of my cultural identities or one of the groups I belong to, I'm sure they would have felt the same. And the way that that was kind of indicated to me, the reason I felt uncool was because of these status symbols, because of what people were wearing. And there was a sense of convergence here, but there was also a norm of independence and a norm of authenticity that we've
been talking about a lot. But underlying all that, there is trends. There are trends that to be cool, we have to both follow and we have to both violate. So how do trends and ideas of in-group prototypicality emerge in these environments? How do we know what to follow and what not to follow? You know, why is it that, you know, you might be in a specific situation, you notice that everyone looks the same. Surely there's like not a big group chat that thousands of people are using
经常被讨论。但在所有这些现象的背后，存在着一些趋势。有些趋势为了显得酷，我们既要去追随，又得去打破。那么，趋势以及内群体典型性的理念是如何在这些环境中产生的呢？我们怎么知道该追随什么、不该追随什么？你知道的，为什么在某些特定情况下，你会发现每个人看起来都长得一样？当然不可能有一个成千上万人在使用的巨大群聊
to like coordinate their outfits and to coordinate what's cool. So how do trends in this kind of globalized environment, how do they emerge? So the origin and the emergence of social conventions of trends, whatever you want to call them, it's kind of been a bit of a problem child for cognitive scientists and social psychologists in the past. And prominent ideas, they've often assumed that institutionalized mechanisms like a centralized authority, figure, leadership, or incentives for collective agreement around norms, these are what are required for shared conventions to become prevalent. Obviously, we know that's not true.
来协调他们的穿着和什么是酷。那么，在这种全球化的环境中，趋势是如何产生的呢？因此，社会习俗、趋势无论你想怎么称呼它们的起源和产生，过去一直是认知科学家和社会心理学家有点头疼的难题。突出的观点通常假设，诸如集中化权威、人物、领导力或围绕规范达成集体协议的激励机制等制度化机制，是共享习俗变得流行所必需的。显然，我们知道这并非事实。
Trends emerge without someone telling us what to do without a collective conversation. When we think about subcultures, which often have a real sense of commonality and a sense of common trends and common conventions, they don't have centralized authorities. They don't have leadership and they don't have kind of solid membership either. So these newer social ideas have kind of come to play and they've suggested that there
趋势的出现并不需要有人告诉我们该做什么，也不需要集体的对话。当我们想到亚文化时，它们通常有一种强烈的共性意识、共同趋势和共同习俗，但它们并没有集中的权威。它们没有领导层，也没有稳固的成员身份。因此，这些较新的社会理念应运而生，并表明
are networks of like locally interacting individuals that kind of spontaneously and unintentionally self-organize and self- and coordinate to produce a more global coordination and trend and convergence towards typical conventions and typical signals of. of status and in-groupness rather than formal institutions. But this kind of sort of self-organisation has been really difficult to demonstrate, especially on a meaningful scale. And that's where all these kind of discussions around, how do we know what's cool?
存在着由本地互动个体组成的网络，他们自发且无意地自我组织、自我协调，从而产生更广泛的全球协调、趋势，以及向典型习俗、典型地位信号和内群体归属感的收敛，而不是依靠正式机构。但这种自我组织一直很难被证明，尤其是在有意义的规模上。这就是所有这些关于“我们怎么知道什么是酷？”的讨论的由来。
How do we know what it means to be part of the in-group? If we don't actually know how the conventions that govern and the norms that govern our in-groups and our groups come to be. but there was this really interesting study that kind of cracked the code or cracked open Pandora's box in some ways. So it was a university study in the Netherlands, I think, and they put these students that were part of like a first year psychology course, they placed them in chat rooms for the entire year. And people were placed randomly in different chat rooms. And over time, these trends started to emerge and how people,
我们怎么知道成为内群体的一员意味着什么？如果我们实际上并不知道支配我们内群体和群体的习俗和规范是如何形成的。但有一项非常有趣的研究在某种程度上破解了密码，或者打开了潘多拉的盒子。那似乎是荷兰的一所大学进行的一项研究，他们把一些一年级心理学专业的学生安排在聊天室里度过了一整年。人们被随机分到了不同的聊天室。随着时间的推移，这些趋势开始在人们身上显现出来，
talk to each other, the jokes they made. And there was also like a convergence within these little groups that were defined by these chat rooms on how people took notes, on where people ate lunch, on what people did. And all of these things, all of these indicators of the specific chat rooms, they differed. They differed. And when all of these groups and one of the chat rooms were kind of combined, people still kind of stuck to the groups that were created by those initial kind of conversations. And what the researchers noticed within that was a trendsetter or a leader within these smaller local groups who kind of started doing something from a place of authenticity and autonomy, which we've talked about. And then everyone kind of followed
他们彼此交谈的方式，他们开的玩笑。在由这些聊天室定义的小群体内部，也开始出现关于人们如何记笔记、在哪里吃午饭、做什么事的收敛。所有这些东西，所有这些特定聊天室的指标，都是不同的。它们各不相同。当所有这些群体以及其中一个聊天室合并时，人们仍然坚持那些由最初对话所创建的群体。研究人员在其中注意到的是，这些较小本地群体中的一个潮流引领者或领导者，出于我们讨论过的真实性和自主性，开始做某事，然后每个人都效仿
suit. We would call them a trend setter. But why was this person more influential? than the other ones than the other people. So I think we know from just our basic knowledge of social interactions and of society in general, social media as well, that not everyone can kind of be a trendsetter or start a social movement towards a particular convention or norm or action. So we typically believe it's tied to charisma, natural intelligence, attractiveness, things like that. But on a deeper level, it has to do with in-group prototypicality. So in-group prototypicality, that is the key that seems to unlock this whole kind of secret closet and strange world.
效仿。我们会称他们为潮流引领者。但为什么这个人比其他人更有影响力呢？我想我们仅凭对社会互动和一般社会的常识，以及社交媒体的了解就知道，并不是每个人都能成为潮流引领者，或者发起一场针对特定规范、习俗或行动的社会运动。所以我们通常认为这与个人魅力、天生智力、吸引力之类的事物有关。但从更深层次来看，这与内群体典型性有关。因此，内群体典型性，似乎就是解开这个神秘衣橱和奇妙世界的关键。
That was a really weird Narnia reference, but you know what I mean, of social attraction and being perceived as cool. So in-group prototypicality, basically what it means is that you are the most, you are kind of the media. the most central and normal bigger of all those around you. You kind of represent the amalgamation of the attributes, the characteristics, the likes, the behaviours, the attitudes of all those who might be within kind of your atmosphere and within your social atmosphere. And people recognise that. You're the person who has the most kind of relatability to every other member of the group.
那是个非常奇怪的纳尼亚纳兰，但你知道我的意思，关于社会吸引力和被认为很酷的梗。因此，内群体典型性，基本上意味着你是所有人中最核心、最正常、最大众化的那个。你代表了在你周围、在你的社会氛围中的所有人的属性、特征、喜好、行为和态度的融合。人们认可这一点。你是与群体中其他成员最具共鸣的人。
and what comes with that is a sense of trust, a sense of trust from other members that you'll do the right thing by them, that they should follow you. And with that comes charisma and attraction and the emergence of a trend set of a trend seter. So in-group prototypicality, being the most familiar and typical member of a group is what gives you the power, one individual the power, to set a convention that is then carried on by others. But navigating that is so not simple. Some people just fall into that role naturally and find group membership and acceptance and leadership, whereas others are kind of really forced to examine group dynamics and trends and figure out where they sit. The good thing is all humans and all groups, they kind of leave a track or a pattern of
随之而来的是一种信任感，来自其他成员的信任，相信你会为他们做正确的事，相信他们应该跟随你。随之而来的是魅力、吸引力和潮流引领者的诞生。因此，内群体典型性，作为群体中最熟悉、最具代表性的成员，赋予了你权力，赋予了某个个体制定随后被他人继承的习俗的权力。然而，驾驭这一点绝对不简单。有些人自然而然地落入这个角色，找到了群体归属感、接纳和领导力，而另一些人则被迫审视群体动态和趋势，并弄清楚自己的位置。好消息是，所有人类和所有群体都留下了
behavior that can be followed and emulated if you really want to be part of the in-group, if you try hard enough to be cool. but the other thing that we've learnt is that always converging on the norms, on the conventions, on the trends that define the groups that you think are important isn't probably going to get you to a point where you feel accepted. It kind of comes more naturally to those who are authentic and who act independently. These are the trendsetters. These are the people who aren't seeking social acceptance. These are the people who gain social acceptance from violating norms, not just obeying them. You know, we can talk about the research behind this, but I think it
如果你真的很想成为内群体的一员，如果你足够努力想变得很酷，行为是可以被遵循和效仿的。但我们学到的另一件事是，一味地去趋同那些定义你认为重要的群体的规范、习俗和趋势，可能不会让你达到一种感到被接纳的境界。对于那些真实且独立行事的人来说，这一切来得更自然。这些人就是潮流引领者。这些人不是在寻求社会接纳。这些人是通过打破规范而不是仅仅服从规范来获得社会接纳的。你知道，我们可以讨论背后的研究，但我认为它
comes from a more anecdotal place and a more kind of, yeah, anecdotal perspective. When you try too hard to be seen as someone who everyone should like and to be socially accepted, often it has the inverse effect. No one likes you. They can tell that you're being fake. They can tell that you're not authentic. They can tell that you don't naturally know how to follow the norms of the group.
来自于一个更具轶事色彩的地方，以及一种更倾向于，是的，轶事视角的观点。当你过于努力地想被看作是一个人人都应该喜欢、并且被社会接纳的人时，往往会产生相反的效果。没有人喜欢你。他们能看出你在伪装。他们能看出你不真实。他们能看出你并不自然地知道如何遵守群体的规范。
Trying hard is uncool. So I guess the lesson from all this conversation is the way to kind of gain social acceptance is to be independent, autonomous and your authentic self. That way you end up kind of drifting and finding the groups who you actually have more in common with naturally, but people are more attracted to you because they see you as somewhat of a leader and an independent thinker and as someone who is self-actualized.
用力过猛是不酷的。所以我想所有这些对话的教训是，获得社会接纳的方法是保持独立、自主和真实的自我。这样你最终会漂流并找到那些你自然拥有更多共同点的群体，而且人们会更被你吸引，因为他们视你为某种程度上的领导者、独立思考者以及一个自我实现的人。
As Maslow said, that is what makes you the most powerful in social interactions is not actually needing social acceptance. I hope you enjoyed this episode. I do realize it was a lot more theoretical-based. and kind of like weird ramblings from me than our typical episodes are. But I really enjoyed looking into this. I think it's something I've been thinking about a lot, having moved recently, it's not really recently anymore, having moved at the start of the year,
正如马斯洛所说，这正是你在社交互动中最强大的地方——实际上并不需要社会接纳。我希望你喜欢这一集。我确实意识到，与我们平时的节目相比，这一集更多的是基于理论，更像是我的一些奇怪的胡思乱想。但我真的很喜欢深入研究这个。我想这是我最近搬家后经常思考的问题，其实也不算最近了，是在今年年初搬家之后，
it's like, how do you figure out how to fit in in a social situation and circumstances that you don't really know very well? And why is it that we're constantly seeking to be liked and socially accepted and seeking symbols or indicators of status. So I guess that's where this episode kind of came from is just me unpacking how that kind of area and element of the social world really works and what things we should consider,
这就像是，你如何在一个你并不太了解的社交情境和环境中弄清楚如何融入？为什么我们不断地寻求被喜欢、被社会接纳，并寻找地位的象征或指标？所以我想这就是这一集的由来，也就是我剖析社会世界的这一领域和要素是如何运作的，以及我们应该考虑哪些事情，
what kind of topics and conversations and subjects come up. So if you're thinking of feeling a similar way, I hope you enjoyed this. I hope as weird as it was, as convoluted as it was, you kind of took something away from it. And thank you for listening if you've made it this far. As I always say, if you have made it this far and you feel cool to do so, please consider leaving the podcast a review on either Apple Podcasts or Spotify.
会涉及哪些话题、对话和科目。因此，如果你也有类似的感觉，我希望你喜欢这个节目。尽管它很奇怪，尽管它很纠结，但我希望你从中有所收获。如果你已经听到了这里，非常感谢你的收听。正如我常说的，如果你听到了这里并且觉得可以这样做，请考虑在苹果播客或声田上给这个播客留下评价。
It really helps us grow. And when I say us, it's just me. So it really, yeah, it makes me really happy to see that people are enjoying this. People are enjoying me being my authentic self, even if it's not cool. But yeah, thank you again for listening and tune in next time. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really
这确实有助于我们的成长。当我说是我们时，其实只有我一个人。所以，是的，看到人们喜欢这个节目，看到人们喜欢真实的自我，即使它并不酷，真的让我很高兴。但是，是的，再次感谢大家的收听，我们下期节目再见。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方
not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难一课》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、体能背后的科学，
and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
并在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方的《TWO%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定亲自采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。